we've talked before about how the
post-trump dr anthony fauci
is sort of a new dr fauci who both feels
that the pandemic is being managed
more competently and feels that he can
simply stick to medical advice without
having to kind of calculate what he says
from the standpoint of
whether the administration will like it
or won't they like it that's a different
dr
fauci than we saw during the trump
administration and dr
fauci was interviewed yesterday on cnn
and went
right at one of the most notable it's
not even really a hypocrisy it's really
a contradiction
by the american right wing on the
pandemic they want everything to be over
but they refuse to do the things that
will accelerate the end of the pandemic
they want to go back to normal but they
couldn't even avoid
bars and big parties for a few months in
2020
and of course they're saying open
everything now it's time to end
everything from a social perspective but
now they don't want to get vaccinated i
told you last week 43
of republicans uh say they don't want
the vaccine and they don't plan to get
it unless for some reason they
have no choice so dr fauci was asked
about it yesterday on cnn he calls it
like it is he explains that
the people who most claim to want
everything to be over
are actually making it go longer by
their opposition to the vaccine and
their other actions take a look
our new poll this week shows that 43
percent of republicans still don't want
to get the vaccine
how frustrating is this for you dr fauci
you know dana it is quite frustrating
because
the fact that one may not want to get
vaccinated in this case
a disturbingly large proportion of
republicans
only actually works against where they
want to be
they want to be able to say these
restrictions that are put on by public
health recommendations
are things that they're very concerned
about we're all concerned about that we
share that concern
but the way you get rid of those
restrictions is to get as many people
vaccinated as quickly
and as expeditiously as possible because
when that happens
for absolutely certain you're going to
see the level of virus in the community
go down and down and down to the point
where you would not have to have
those public health restrictions so it's
almost paradoxical
that on the one hand they want to be
relieved of the restrictions
but on the other hand they don't want to
get vaccinated it just almost doesn't
make any sense
paradoxical is exactly the right word
to apply to this situation now it's also
hopeless
for dr fauci to expect these very people
to go and get the vaccine dr fauci wants
the people
who are against abortion but don't want
easier access to contraception to
realize that
they could end the pandemic sooner if
they got vaccinated and this exists a
ton on the right we are against abortion
no matter what
okay great well let's reduce demand for
abortions to do that we prevent unwanted
pregnancy well what prevents unwanted
pregnancy
access to contraception comprehensive
sex
ed oh but they're also against that what
it's the exact same thing
dr fauci said it almost doesn't make any
sense i would remove the word almost
it just doesn't make any sense and very
little we're going to talk later about
this actually
very little of the modern republican
party makes any sense it's not just
their position on ending the pandemic if
you want to talk about other things that
make no sense
consider the big picture on vaccines
from these people
the virus isn't serious it's just like
the flu so everything can stay open
but trump is developing a vaccine which
he deserves credit for
which they're not going to take anyway
but he'd better get the credit for it
even though we don't need it and they
won't take it and the pandemic's not
serious anyway well done hold on a
second
then why is it that trump's a hero for
developing the vaccine
you won't take and don't need and by the
way what is pro-life about their
positions on any of these things they
don't want to get the vaccine
nor wear a mask but they want to end the
pandemic our patients
for this nonsense should be very very
low and i've said this before
and it's maybe a good point to end on
rights come with responsibilities i have
an entire youtube segment about this
that you can find
to just go around demanding rights
absent and completely ignoring the
responsibilities that come with them
is not a recipe for a well-functioning
society and unfortunately we're gonna
have to go around them or
through them in order to fix this
situation um
they're not going to work with us and
that's maybe the the worst part of all
of it because
uh people who are doing the right things
are still going to suffer
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
deepakman one of our sponsors today is
blueblox i spend a lot of time because
of my work looking at a computer screen
and peer-reviewed studies have
shown that the blue light that comes
from screens can actually lead to
certain types of
eye strain and even damage or blurred
vision headaches
dry watery eyes blue blocks fixes this
by filtering out the blue light and
unlike other cheap blue light glasses
the effectiveness of blue blocks glasses
are backed up
by evidence and they're built under
optics laboratory conditions
these are my blue blocks glasses i like
how they look they have over 40
different styles to choose from
i really have noticed a big difference
where i'm no longer
getting that eye strain and headaches
from the computer screen
because of the blue blocks glasses they
have prescription versions and
non-prescription
and readers they have something for
every need and blue blocks is giving you
20 off when you go to blue blocks dot
com slash pacman and use the code pacman
the link is under this video and you'll
get free shipping on orders over 115
dollars